I've got great news for you it is
February 1st we did it we Regis 2100
patreon contributors which is going to
trigger the production and release of
the multi-part critical thinking
miniseries I'm triggered upad has been
fully triggered by this the backstory is
patreon exists and we use it to raise
money when you go to patreon.com/scishow
you are able to make a contribution of
as little as $1 a month and we set a
target not in terms of money but in
terms of patrons and we said when we get
to 2100 patrons we will go forward with
this really pretty major undertaking of
producing the 12 to 15 part critical
thinking miniseries and early last week
we had about a hundred patrons to go
late last week we had 85 patrons to go
early this week we had around 50 patrons
to go the numbers shrunk and yesterday
we had only 18 patrons to go and we
reached a high of 2120 patrons late last
night of course that number has started
to trail off as the February first
credit card processing has started and
some people's credit cards have expired
but I'm we said yeah we don't have to
stay over 2100 as long as we hit 2100
that's good enough for us so this is
just gonna be awesome yeah I mean it's
not like it's okay we want to crawl back
up of course still hit the goal we're
gonna follow through with that's exactly
right
there will be follow-through I am
sticking to my word it's not like when
Trump said Melania would do a press
conference and tell us all about why she
was working illegally in the United
States I said we're gonna release this
thing and we're going to release this
thing we have two great sponsors for the
critical thinking miniseries companies
that value critical thinking which is
why they're sponsoring their critical
thinking miniseries so thanks to
everybody and let's move on to the next
thing already right which is when we hit
2500 patrons we are going to record edit
and upload my Boston College lectures
from the class that I taught in the fall
at Boston College along with slides and
visuals that will be so this is a 12 to
15
part miniseries of three to seven minute
clips that next project at 2500 patrons
is a dozen 75 minute lectures that
you're going to be producing and
releasing which I also think people will
really like we've got to start working
on that now well I'm gonna get right to
it now listen let's let's release the
critical thinking miniseries first but
yet 2500 is the next goal patreon.com
slash David Pakman show
let's make it happen